hey what's up mrs. John Delaney with
Ramsey Network welcome back to the
YouTube show today I'm taking more
emails about your anxiety about your
relationships about work these are from
you so here we go all right hi dr. John
what's up my name is Heather and I get
real nervous and anxious before work I
work 12-hour swing shifts and I work on
and off two to four days at a time with
days off frequently every time it's time
to go back to work after being off a day
or two I get nervous and my guts and
gets sick just the day before I seem to
worry a lot about it what may I need to
do or change to help this problem I also
did this with another job in the past
thanks for the email Heather I've been
there you got to go to work it's the
next day it's about nine o'clock at
night and you know you need to be
winding down and get ready for bed and
you got that churn that yeah well then
suddenly you get that what I call my
fake headaches and my fake like I don't
sleep very well so then the only way to
make it better is to eat junk food and
then watch a series on something and
suddenly it's 11:45 and I got to be up
at 6:30 and get out the door I'm late
I'm frustrated I don't feel good I got
that anxious feeling and this isn't the
only job that's happened to you all
that's happened a couple of other jobs
which tells me a few things number one
you're working shift work the World
Health Organization has identified shift
work as a carcinogen because you don't
get full sleep you don't have good
routine you don't have good
relationships people who work shift work
often grab fast food on the way to work
they don't have good nutrition it just
messes everything up so if your last
jobs have been shift work you're gonna
have to be very hyper intentional about
setting a routine about eating well and
really really protecting your sleep
and most of all having connected
relationships and that's hard when you
don't all get home at five o'clock and
you all can go to dinner together or
it's hard when you don't all have the
same Saturday morning plans I get that
you were gonna have to be hyper
intentional Heather you're gonna have to
have to have to focus number two it may
be the kind of work you're doing these
are twelve hour shifts so I'm gonna
guess
you are a nurse in an ER you are a
firewoman or you're a surgeon and you're
working 12-hour shifts where you're
operating on brains or maybe you're
working on an oil rig out in the Gulf I
don't know but if you're working 12-hour
shifts at a job that's high high stress
with high high consequences then you've
got to be hyper intentional about taking
care of yourself taking care of your
community taking care of your
relationships all the stuff I just said
the last thing I want you to look at
Heather is this do you get nervous or
anxious before other things in your life
do you get anxious or nervous before
church before a date before your parents
come home to town or is it just about
work because if you get anxious or
nervous about other things when you
watch the news does your heart start
racing or if you see something about
climate change do you get that drop in
your stomach right or when you have to
stop and get gas in the car whatever it
may be I want you to step back from
focusing just on work I want you to look
around your entire ecosystem take a look
at your at your kitchen and see are
other places on fire because if it's
just about your job then that's an
answer in and of itself but if you're
struggling with anxiety in other places
you know you've got to do some deeper
heart work on Heather because it's not
the jobs fault it may be the
accountabilities fault it may be the
ecosystems fault it may be some deep
stuff you've got to deal with but you're
asking the right questions and there is
light at the end of this thank you so
much for your email Heather and while
we're here let's get one more email in
hey dr. D I've got a relationship
question for you sweet my girlfriend and
I have been very intentional while
dating with the intent of determining if
we should get married or not since day
one that's a lot of pressure man but
I'll continue we spent time while single
figuring out what we wanted and needed
in a partner and we've decided that
we've gotten more than we ever could
have imagined I know where this is
headed we have read three or four
marriage books together already and we
have a vision for the future that aligns
well we want to bring glory to God and
pursue first the kingdom of heaven but
I've been struggling with how friends an
extended family will react to engagement
marriage after only four months of
dating
what I thought was gonna happen I'm
hoping for some wisdom and I'm hoping
you could help me out by the way I'm 24
and she is 22 and we both have great
careers as an engineer and a project
manager
thanks Nathaniel dude Nathaniel thanks
for the email couple of quick thoughts
here number one slow down
number two you met somebody and she met
you and you instantly put a ton of
pressure on a new relationship you
looked at each other and said hey I'm
Nathaniel
hi I'm whoever is this forever can we
make this work that's a lot that's a lot
when you put that kind of pressure on a
marriage you start looking about what
this relationships gonna do for us what
this relationships gonna do for me and
for you and where we're going and you
forget to just learn how to be friends
you forget just to learn how to hang out
you forget to look for the little things
like what makes you laugh what color are
your eyes what do you find silly what
kind of terrible music do you like how
do you respond to stress when the world
shuts down you get so excited so focused
on these goals
you get three or four marriage books to
make sure you're following all the maps
and you've got your end result in mind
you know where the finish line of the
marathon is gonna be but you forget to
enjoy just going for a run I do love
agile of a shared value system you're
already talking about your faith you're
talking about who you want to be what do
you want any other partner that's
awesome it's all good stuff in rich
stuff if you want to get married after
four months knock your lights out man as
I often tell people on this channel your
friends your family if they're not in
your box they don't get a vote man you
get to decide who you listen to but I'll
tell you if you want to get married
after four months the deck is stacked
against you because you know where the
finish line is man you don't know how to
enjoy the person on the way you can't
learn that kind of stuff in books you
can't learn that kind of stuff in four
months time so my recommendation
whatever it's worth is to slow down
become friends first laughs first
getting water balloon fights together go
wrap somebody's house with toilet paper
like he's doing your kid
eat together go for walks together slow
down slow down and if you value the
wisdom of your community of your family
seek that wisdom out and if they know
you as a person who makes quick
decisions and it's always jumping into
the first thing they're gonna take to
slow down or if they know her and they
say whoa she jumps into things
impulsively and they gonna tell you they
slow down that's what your community is
for but if they don't get a vote they
don't get a vote
and if you want to get married let me
know all high-five you brother and I'll
be supporting you all the way and by the
way I got married at 24 - my wife was 23
but we knew each other for five years
and I've been with the same woman for a
long time a long time and I'm still
learning things about her that I didn't
know I thought I did I didn't know
there's no pressure on you man
exhale you found an awesome girl man
that's so good but you've got a lifetime
ahead of you continue getting to know
each other it's been some time exhaling
and you've got this send me an invite to
the wedding whenever it happens this is
dr. John Delaney make sure you subscribe
send the emails all that stuff follow me
ATS at the whatever's and I'll talk to
you soon take care